you
imagine you own a watch that lets you
travel through time one day you get the
bright idea to travel back to the 1920s
to mess with your grandparents you press
a few buttons and suddenly you're
standing beside old Pappy who's taking
in the scenery at the precipice of the
Grand Canyon since you've never been the
biggest fan of your grandfather you
decide to push him over the edge
gravity does its thing and a few seconds
later no more Pappy but wait if you
killed your grandfather before he ever
met your grandmother you wouldn't have
been born to be able to go back in time
and kill him here's the problem if you
didn't exist to kill your grandfather
you couldn't have killed him because you
didn't kill him he's still alive but
that would mean that you yourself would
be alive and now you can go back in time
to kill him and so the endless loop goes
on this is called the grandfather
paradox and it's part of what makes time
travel so interesting the grandfather
paradox deals with time travel on a
significant scale but why don't we start
with something a little smaller let's
say you and I are wearing identical
watches and we synchronize them right
before I blast off into space in the
Space Shuttle I'm traveling at roughly
28,000 kilometres per hour relative to
the earth if I make a few orbits around
the earth before I return when we
compare watches we'll see that less time
has passed for me a very very tiny
amount of time but is there nonetheless
this is called time dilation and it
simply means that according to
Einstein's theory of relativity time
measured along different trajectories is
affected by differences in either
gravity or velocity each of which
affects time in different ways
one example of time dilation is when we
compare the passage of time on the ISS
versus on earth after spending six
months on the space station astronauts
have aged approximately point zero zero
five seconds less than those of us here
on earth of course this is a very
insignificant amount of time but it
would be much more apparent if the
astronauts were able to travel closer to
the speed of light interestingly the
effects of time dilation are fairly
minor even up to around 70 percent the
speed of light however once we reach 75
percent or so the effects become
dramatic now bear with me here because
this is where things get a bit weird
possibly the strangest aspect of special
relativity is that distances shrink in
the direction of motion when we think of
traveling to a point 10 light-years away
at 90 percent of light speed you would
expect it to take 11 years right that's
not exactly the case to a stationary
observer it would indeed seemed
take your vessel 11 years but to the
people inside the vessel not only time
but distance would dilate and you would
reach that point in only four point four
years want to play with time-dilation
yourself I've added a link down below to
a time dilation calculator okay that's
all really fascinating but is it really
time travel perhaps not in the sense
that we usually think of it but
according to the nature of space-time it
is if you were to return home from your
90% Lightspeed trip you would be almost
nine years older but everyone back on
earth would have aged 22 years
so in essence you've traveled 13 years
into the future relative to your time in
space let's look at another example in
the film interstellar Cooper and his
team land on a large watery planet on
which gravity is 30% stronger than on
earth this planet is situated very close
to a supermassive black hole called
gargantuan which it orbits at 55% the
speed of light Gargantuas mass is equal
to that of a hundred million suns and
spins at 99.8% the speed of light the
combination of all these factors have
the effect of slowing down time relative
to the astronaut left aboard the ship by
a staggering 61 thousand times that
means that one hour on the planet is
equal to seven years aboard the ship
when the team makes it back to the
vessel after a little over three of
their hours their friend at age by 23
years the craziest part is that this
isn't just science fiction those
calculations all check out
that's exactly how it would happen in
real life so in essence the crew had
traveled 23 years into the future now so
far we've only explored traveling into
the future
is it possible to travel backwards in
time according to some theories specific
types of motion in space might allow
time travel into the past and future if
these geometries and motions were
possible however that's a big if it
would require something called a closed
timelike curve or CTC for short a CTC is
a closed loop in space-time which could
theoretically allow an object to return
to its own past the science behind time
travel to the past is incredibly complex
and speculative and many scientists
suspect that it's not possible at all
because of the issue of causality that
brings us back to the grandfather
paradox if in fact these scientists are
correct in assuming traveling to the
past would cause a paradox then we have
our answer time travel to the past is
impossible if however the Novikov
self-consistency principle is correct
then there's still a chance the Novikov
principle states that if an event exists
that would cause a paradox or any change
to the past whatsoever then the
probability of that event is zero it
would thus be impossible to create time
paradoxes
unfortunately for any would-be time
travelers the Novikov principle is not
widely accepted another possibility
would be the existence of wormholes
which are technically permitted by
general relativity in order to travel
through time using a wormhole it would
have to be what is known as a
transversal wormhole brace yourself for
more strange spacetime shenanigans here
in order to be able to travel through
time using a transversal wormhole its
creation would have to be in one of two
ways option 1 one end of the wormhole
would have to be accelerated to a
significant portion of the speed of
light then brought back to the origin
point time dilation would result in the
accelerated wormhole entrance aging less
than the stationary one as seen by an
external observer option 2 requires one
end of the wormhole to be placed within
the gravitational field of an object
with higher gravity than the other
entrance and then returned to a position
near the other entrance this is a
difficult concept to grasp so think of
it this way imagine you and I
synchronized our watches to both display
the year 2000 I hop in my ship and
accelerate one entrance to the wormhole
to near light speed then bring it back
my watch now reads 2004 and yours reads
2012 if someone were then to enter the
accelerated entrance they would now exit
the stationary entrance in the year 2000
for the same location but eight years in
their past it's incredibly complicated
stuff but an easier way to look at it is
by picturing a piece of paper this paper
represents space-time a wormhole is an
area of warped space-time with an
entrance and an exit which you can
imagine as the paper being folded back
on itself with a whole book through it
essentially you're simply skipping all
the time and distance between the two
points
the problem with transversal wormholes
is that you can't possibly travel back
further than the initial creation of the
wormhole so really it's more of a path
through time rather than a device that
propels itself back and forth through
the years at will it could be useful for
people in the distant future wanting to
come observe our time but if we created
such a portal today we couldn't use it
to go visit the dinosaurs one final
method that could potentially allow an
individual to more or less travel
through time is cryopreservation the
branch of science concerned specifically
with preserving humans is called
cryonics and
practice has been around since the late
1960s cryonics is on the speculative
edge of medicine as its proponents
suggest that death is not a singular
event but a process it would have to be
for the practice to be successful
because it's currently illegal for a
human to be frozen before they die one a
person has opted to be cryopreserved
their body's prepared minutes after
official death the theory is that by
reducing the patient's body temperature
to around negative 130 degrees Celsius
enough brain information will be
retained in an accessible state for
doctors and scientists of the far future
to revive the patient temperatures that
low inevitably cause significant damage
to the human body regardless of prior
preservation safeguards so the doctors
of today are relying on the development
of future technology that will allow the
brain to be repaired at the molecular
level and restored to functioning
condition if someday technology has
advanced far enough to revive
cryopreserved humans they will have
essentially time travel to the future
it's not quite as easy as shows like
feature AMA make it seem but it is
theoretically possible and that's time
travel in a nutshell you really can move
forward through time by traveling at
immense speeds or through
cryopreservation but travel to the past
is likely impossible of course the
science of quantum physics and time
travel is incredibly vast and well
beyond the grasp of most normal people
so we may be missing just one crucial
element to understanding exactly how
space-time works but who knows maybe
someone from the far future will show up
in our time and give us the key to
unlocking the mystery or would that
cause a paradox as always I've included
sources and links for further reading in
the description if you enjoyed this
video please take a moment to subscribe
to my channel your support helps me keep
releasing two videos every week feel
free to leave a like or a dislike as you
please and share your thoughts on time
travel in the comments thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video